[Applause]
[Music]
Rihanna pulling out the Fenty for a
little touch up during her Super Bowl
halftime performance all women deserve
to feel beautiful yeah but Riri takes
the stage at the big game as the Kansas
City Chiefs face off against the
Philadelphia Eagles and makes it a
moment to shamelessly plug her beauty
brand
[Applause]
[Music]
leading up to the Super Bowl Rihanna's
company's socials got in the game day
Spirit too
the event marks the Stars highly
anticipated return to music after
spending seven years focusing on
building her business Empire
[Music]
I've always tried to stay and stick with
things that I enjoy doing and mostly
that I'm passionate about being creative
that's one of those things that it
doesn't matter the outlet I always enjoy
it
[Music]